my friend Jack besobic is apparently on
a Ukraine hit list
You Know Jack
conservative journalists speaker you've
seen him and about he and I have done
events together and been on each other's
shows and anyway Ukraine apparently
wants to Murder Jack
it's not good
how did I find this out well uh because
there's this website
that that
lists enemies of Ukraine and it's
supposedly an unofficial website but it
looks a little bit sort of affiliated
with the country
uh
what what Jack said here is after the
collapse of his counter-offensive
zielinski's biggest threat is not me
it's his own intelligence Services hope
you don't get put on the cia's early
retirement plan Vlad drop the receipts
on the bidens and we'll get you a nice
big mansion in Sarasota uh so so Jack's
on this list
list includes Tulsi gabbard prime
minister Victor Orban Roger Waters from
Pink Floyd because he's spoken out
against Ukraine I'm pleased to see I'm
not on the list even though I did this
long Thread about the Ukraine military
spokesman who's an American dude who
dresses up like a chick uh I'm at least
as far as I can tell I'm not on this
list uh the the organization that puts
out the list is called mirotovores which
ironically translates to Peacemaker they
say it's separate from the government
but I don't really buy it because it was
founded in 2014 by a former Ukraine
government Minister George Tuka it's
it's reported to be run by a former
member of Ukraine State intelligence
under an alias Roman zaitsev
and according to the times of London the
list has been used by government
officials at checkpoints in Ukraine
in addition to official government
databases
so
when that uh psycho spokesman for the
Ukraine military
the American
when he said
that he didn't really threaten any
journalists
that's a lie first of all it's a lie
because we saw the video
where he said any Russian propagandists
were hunting you down but now we see the
list
and the list includes
not only journalists but American
journalists
not only American journalists but Jack
besobic
sure looks like that was the case and
sure looks like it it uh undercuts the
liberal's argument that they're the
great Defenders of Journalism no they're
not and the argument that journalism
that's the fourth estate the people who
speak truth to power it's not that
either
political forces have
spokesman political forces have people
who articulate and communicate those
views
and
the Liberals view their opposing
journalists as enemies here and abroad
and they view their journalists as not
the speakers of Truth to power they view
them as propagandists which is often
what they are right now go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles living a healthy lifestyle is
not easy especially when you're always
on the go you need simple manageable
routines to make sure you're getting the
proper nutrition every day which is why
I'm a fan of balance of nature balance
of nature fruits and veggies are a great
way to make sure you're getting
essential nutrition every day their
capsules are packed with 100 whole food
that you can take at any time balance of
nature uses a cold vacuum process that
preserves the natural phytonutrients in
whole fruits and vegetables and
encapsulates them for easy consumption
balance of nature sent a bunch of their
products down to the studio for our team
to try we all love them make fruits and
veggies a part of your daily diet your
body will thank you go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code nulls
kwles for 35 off your first order as a
preferred customer that is
balanceofnature.com promo code Knolls
for 35 off your first order my only
recommendation is when you receive it
don't receive it at the daily wire
office where these jackals of producers
and assistants come and steal them all
head on over right now
balanceofnature.com promo code Knowles
one story I got to get to this is so
this is a creepiest story I've seen in a
long time a teenage girl found an iPhone
in an airplane bathroom and a was an
iPhone underneath the seat or behind the
seat to basically catch her naked and
this was after a flight attendant a male
flight attendant on I think it was
American Airlines
told her hey come up to the use the
bathroom in the first class cabin and
then he was in there first then she goes
in uses the bathroom then she sees him
go back in there presumably to take this
iPhone the family is extremely Disturbed
as well they should be my my thought on
this is I mean I hope the family sues I
hope this guy goes the guy ended up
getting arrested apparently once the
plane landed but my main thought on this
uh other than just revulsion and disgust
is
how many things had to go wrong in this
guy's life how many bad turns did this
guy have to take to get to the point
where he was planting a camera in an
airplane bathroom for a 14 year old girl
to film her in states of undress in kind
of disgusting states of unrest too
because you're in a bathroom
how how perverted do you have to be
and then it reminded me
of one of the great Norm Macdonald bits
about Bill Cosby and hypocrisy as my
buddy says the worst part about Cosby
was he was a hypocrite and I said I
don't think that was the worst part
it's being the worst part of the raping
way up high
and then the second would be the
drugging
and then the third would be the
scheming
but anyways hypocrisy would be way down
the line you know like on the fourth
page or something yes that exactly as
usual Norm is right and
the libs will say well the worst crime
is hypocrisy that's the worst crime
that's why the Liberals will jump with
joy and applaud and be so happy about
depraved sexual acts taking place at
Pride parades that's why they'll be so
thrilled and happy about drag queen
Story Hour inviting
to go talk to five-year-olds they'll be
they'll say it's wonderful it's
expressive it's great but then Lauren
bobert gets caught on a hidden camera in
a in a dark theater or doing things that
are that are untoward and they'll try to
throw the book at her because what they
say is no it's not what she did it's the
hypocrisy that's the worst part
which by the way they confuse hypocrisy
with just having standards and failing
to live live up to them which is called
sinning which is called being human
but yeah hypocrisy hypocrisy is bad
failing to have a standard is bad being
an active hypocrite and pretending to
have a standard and then intentionally
uh undermining that that's worse that's
true
but like what about the
what about the scheming you know that to
me that's the darkest part of the story
like no the darkest part is that this 14
year old girl was traumatized in an
airplane bathroom that's the worst part
but the most unsettling part of it
is all the scheming think about how much
this guy sat at home scheming and
thinking and entertaining bizarre
thoughts in his head and you know this
guy is completely addicted to porn and I
bet this guy's looking at pretty creepy
porn if he's doing this to a 14 year old
girl and just the his entire life must
be just filled like a room filled with
with just poison gas with just all of
this hideous stuff and all of which is
to say it's a reminder
to get off that path early before
because it can get really really bad to
get off that path early this is the
wisdom the traditional Christian wisdom
of avoiding the near occasion of sin
this one moment you're entertaining
weird thoughts the next Mo you know
maybe you're looking at bad stuff
whatever and then the next moment you
find yourself as an airplane Steward
doing really creepy stuff
at thirty thousand feet boy what a great
clip that was now make sure that you
ring the bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles Show podcast see you next time